this from the post-millennial says
accused cry bully taylor lorenz said she
has suffered severe ptsd from being a
journalist
and broke down in an
msnbc interview on friday on friday's
meet the press daily show on msnbc host
chuck todd briefly discussed government
statistics about online harassment and
women before turning it over to
correspondent morgan radford who uh did
an interview
with washington post columnist lorenz
who covers technology and online culture
um so let's let's begin first with the
setup from chuck todd
talking about this uh problem of online
harassment and he says that it's a it's
a problem that
especially impacts women and especially
female journalists they're the victims
of this let's listen to
that welcome back this week the white
house proclaimed april as national
sexual assault awareness and prevention
month one of the fastest growing threats
to women is online harassment the latest
government statistics show one in three
women under the age of 35 have
experienced a type of essentially sexual
harassment online it's often
underreported and many times not taken
seriously despite its serious risk to
mental health and physical safety the
administration is now committed to a new
global partnership for action on
gender-based online harassment and abuse
the goal deliver an action plan and
combating technology facilitated
gender-based violence by the end of this
year morgan radford joins me now she's
been doing some reporting on the impact
of this type of harassment especially
uh the impact it has on women in
journalism and it's not even a close
call morgan as nasty as the attacks can
be on on some of us in this business if
you're a woman it is at another level
that's right chuck and you know before
this was all sort of anecdotal but now
we have hard data i mean this is one of
the biggest issues facing female
journalists right now
well
we'll get to the um
the actual example because they do bring
in in fairness
they bring in
because if you're skeptical
well they have us they have a victim
story that they share with us
but i actually think that chuck todd
understates the problem to begin with
because he says that one in three women
under the age of 35
experience online harassment well
it's actually three in three women under
the age of 35 and uh three and three
women of any age who have been online
for more than 30 seconds have been
harassed but the other thing is that
that's also true for men like literally
anyone who has spent more than half an
hour on the internet at any point in
their life their lives
has been harassed
it comes with the territory we all
experience it every single one of us and
the the larger of a platform you have
the more people you're interacting with
um
the more people who know that you exist
the more the more that you're gonna be
harassed it's not a good thing i don't
like it
i don't enjoy it
i experience it all the time
you could just sift through my
email inbox
messages comments it's it's all there
so this is this is part of the terror
this is this comes with the territory
with the internet
is it good no it's not good
um
but we can't even begin to have any
serious conversation about this issue
however serious the issue actually is
but we can't begin to really talk about
it if you're determined to talk about it
through the lens of identity politics
and left-wing victimology 101.
if that's how you want to talk about
them we're not going to be able to have
any serious conversation
as evidenced by taylor lorenz uh again
washington post columnist and she she
came on to talk about her experiences by
the way she's also not under the age of
35 i think she's in like her 40s and so
this is the example they give us for
some reason and here she is um talking
about the trauma that she suffered
because of online harassment listen
hey nice job on that
story you soulless effing
then also you'll see there's these
there's many people that are tweeting um
you know here's these are taylor
lorenz's loved ones they have photos wow
these are all photos of your family
members yeah children yeah they'll
threaten children they'll threaten my
parents i've had to remove every single
social tie i had severe ptsd from this i
i contemplated suicide it got really bad
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying
it's horrifying
i'm so sorry
it's overwhelming it's really hard
just put your phone down
lady just put your phone down go do
something else with you if you can't
handle it then do something else with
your life
you're traumatized by your ptsd
i mean there there are people who go
overseas they're in they're in uh
you know armed conflicts they go to war
they come from war and they're not
reacting the way that you are
and even if they do you're putting
yourself when you use a phrase when you
use a term like ptsd
you have post-traumatic stress disorder
you are putting yourself on the same
plane
as um
uh people who watch their friends get
get uh blown to pieces on the
battlefield you're putting yourself in
the same conversation on the same level
you do not have ptsd no you don't
i'm not your psychiatrist i'm not your
therapist i haven't run any any tests at
all on you i've and yet and yet yes i
can sit here from a distance and say you
do not have ptsd
you just need to grow up
this is weakness
you're weak
need to be stronger
or find another line of work
i mean that's the example that she gives
us is someone says uh
uh oh you you soulless c word
i get that ev that's like
600 times a day those sorts of comments
and that's the that's the best you could
do
that's the worst example you can give us
now bringing your family into it all
that kind of stuff that's terrible
that's absolutely terrible it shouldn't
happen
but it happens to all of us happens to
me
i hate it i don't like it
it does that makes me angry once you
bring my my kids and my family into it
but um
we all experience it
without a doubt
there is it is it is true now so there
are two
things to establish here actually there
are three because the first thing we
should point out maybe the most
important thing about taylor lorenz
is that she is guilty of this kind of
thing herself this is what makes it all
the more ironic and ridiculous to bring
her on to talk about it she is one of
the
architects of cancel culture
she has she's one of these quote-unquote
journalists who's whipped up mobs
against people trying to get them
canceled try to get them harassed
trying to foment exactly the kind of
outrage against other people that she
says traumatizes her and how much worse
does that make you
it seems like you are actually kind of
soulless
if you're traumatized by being insulted
by people and yet and so you consider it
to be a traumatizing event and yet you
try to put other people in that position
that just makes you a horrible person
so that's one thing we have to establish
we also have to establish that a lot of
this is it does fall into the category
of just suck it up buttercup and deal
with it
because if you if you have to have to
make a choice
you know anyone with a with a platform
you didn't get it by accident
i know this from experience you have to
work
some some of us harder than others but
you still have to work and actually try
to build a platform the kind of platform
where they even where they're even
asking you to come on cable news and
talk about your experiences
so a lot of effort went into that
and if you're gonna make that effort
then you have to be prepared to deal
with the criticism
and because we live in the modern age we
live in the age of the internet
it's going to be a whole lot of
criticism
and a lot of it's going to be quite
vulgar and maybe a little bit upsetting
but if you can't deal with that then you
can't deal with being a journalist and
you need to find a different line of
work
because the here's the one advantage
this is the great thing
as rough as it is as rough and tumble as
it can get on the internet
the great thing is that it still exists
in your phone
and so you can always just put down your
phone
and live your life
and there's a lot of power in that too
you know i've i've noticed that i feel
that sometimes
when um
when the mob's coming after me and
everybody's really upset about something
that i said and you know i'm getting
thousands of people
coming after me it actually is quite
satisfying that i can just
put my phone down and go fishing or
something
there's all these people out there on
the internet who are so mad and it's
like i don't even know it i'm not even
reading it
so you have that ability
and then the third point
is that
it is also true
that the internet
the anonymity that comes with the
internet
it gives people
they feel licensed
to say the kinds of things that they
would never say to you in person
um
i mean i could say that again it's
something again i could say from
experience that
i talk about all these all these things
people say to me
i've never
encountered it in public
like
every day i could go online check my
inbox whatever look at the comments and
there's all these people saying ah
you're a piece of crap you're this and
that um
nobody has ever come up to me in public
and said that to my face ever not once
so these are all a bunch of cowards for
the most part they hide behind the
anonymity and everything and uh the
internet enables people to do that
and so i think that there is a
conversation that we can have
um
about
why why is it that people act this way
to each other on the internet what does
it say about us
i know we like to think that uh well the
internet isn't the real world and so
it's a totally different thing and
you hear that all the time well twitter
isn't the real world well yes it is it's
the real world because these are actual
human beings who are using this
communication
tool to speak to each other it's it's
the real world and whatever you say on
the internet that's you saying it
now you might want to if you're the kind
of if you are a troll if you're one of
these vicious trolls on the internet and
you say a lot of terrible things
uh you might want to comfort yourself by
telling yourself that's not really me
that's just internet me
that's the me and the youtube comments
i'm telling someone to kill themselves i
would never say that in real life well
you are saying it in real life this is
reality
so we could talk about that what is it
that drives people to behave that way
why does the anonymity bring this out of
people what does it say i mean all these
it's an interesting conversation
at least but we can't really have it
if we again insist on having it through
the lens
of identity politics
the left's uh victimhood hierarchy
because they don't even want to start
the conversation unless they can
establish at the outset
that their preferred victim groups are
the primary victims of this
thing
when in fact this is a ubiquitous
problem
that everybody on the internet
experiences and if we're not going to
acknowledge that
from the outset of the conversation then
there's no point in having the
conversation
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated